where I see people miss each other all
the time is she says I need you to be
more affectionate if you were more
affectionate then I would want to have
sex more and you go into your toolbox of
affectionate that is probably a mix
of and I'm just not pointing at you I'm
say I'm speaking you as males in general
okay a mix of pornography a mix of
conversations you've had maybe a couple
of old girlfriends and just
some
imagination and you dip into that
toolkit and you're like all right
affection here we come and maybe your
mom made you want watch a Hallmark movie
once and that Guy brought flowers and
you're like all right that sounds cool
and what you do is you miss the whole
boat